Merhaba değerli dostum meschemy kimya
kanalına Hoş geldin Evet bugünkü konumuz
maddenin halleri maddenin hallerine
başlıyoruz ilk olarak maddenin fiziksel
halleri ve katılardan bahsedeceğim bugün
bu konu önemli midir Evet önemlidir
Dostum Evet maddenin halleri ile ilgili
ÖSYM genellikle sıvılar kısmından soru
soruyor Ama bu kısımdan da soru
gelebilir soru gelebilecek çok güzel
yerler var detaylarından bahsedeceğim
hatta birkaç tane de örnek getirdim
örneklerden de bahsedeceğim o zaman
vakit kaybetmiyoruz hazırsak başlayalım
maddenin halleri dediğimizde biz dört
tane temel halden bahsedeceğiz bunlardan
birisi katı diğeri sıvı biri gaz Bir
tane de plazma diye bir hal var katı
sıvı gazın birbirine dönüşümünü
Biliyoruz zaten şöyle örneklendir Hatta
şöyle yaklaşarak burada göstereyim
dostum katının sıvıya dönüşmesi olayı
ısı alarak gerçekleşiyor ve erime
olayıydı sıvının katıya dönüşmesi donma
olayıydı ve ısı vererek gerçekleşiyordu
mesela sıvının gaza dönüşmesi nasıldı
buharlaşma olayıydı ve ısı alarak
gerçekleşiyordu gazın tekrar sıvıya
dönüşmesi de ne ol ne oluyordu işte ısı
vererek diyorduk ve yoğuşma olarak ifade
ediyorduk burada Mesela katının gaza
dönüşmesi Süblimleşme olayı ısı alarak
gerçekleşiyor gazın tekrar katıya
dönüşmesi ise ısı vererek gerçekleşiyor
Kırağılaşma Olayı olarak ifade ediyor
oluruz ki bir tane daha var demiştik O
da ney plazma hali O da gazın enerji
alarak plazmaya dönüşmesi olayı
iyonizasyon olayıdır enerji alarak
gerçekleşiyor tekrar plazmanın gaza
dönüşmesi deiyonizasyon olarak ifade
ifade edilmekte Dostum şimdi şu katı
sıvı gazın şeylerini görelim bakalım
özelliklerinden bahsedelim mesela
katılar için ne diyoruz taneciklere
temas halindedir aralarındaki boşluk yok
denecek kadar azdır katıda tanecikler
arası boşluk çok çok azdır ifadesini
kullanabiliriz başka Mesela şunu
söyleyebiliriz katıların yoğunluğu nedir
sıvılardan büyüktür Sadece su ve bizmut
hariç su ve bizmut E onun mesela sıvısı
daha yoğun oluyor katısı sıvısında yüzen
maddeler dediğimizde su ve bizmut
aklımıza gel gelmeli dostum suyu mesela
buz halini suya attığımızda ne oluyor
üstte kalıyor ama onun dışında tüm
neredeyse tüm maddelerin katısı
sıvısının dibine çöker yani diğer bir
ifadeyle katının yoğunluğu sıvılardan
büyük olur diyoruz başka Maddenin en
düzenli hali katı halidir sonra sıvı gaz
diye gidiyor biliyorsun başka
tanecikleri sadece titreşim hareketi
yapmaktadır katıda tanecikler sadece
titreşim hareketi yapmaktadır belirli
Hacim ve şekilleri vardır yani
bıraktığında ne olur belli bir şekle
sahiptir ve hacmini de muhafaza etmekte
dedir diyoruz katılar sıkıştırılamaz ve
katılar akışkan değildir burada akla şu
gelebilir Hocam ben tuzu dökerken böyle
akıyor O sanki akışkan mış gibi geliyor
Hayır orada bir tane tuz kristalini
düşün bak katı haldeki tuz kristalini o
akıyor mu Hayır Orada bir sürü mol şey E
ne katı kristal birbirlerine çarparak
hareket ediyor ama orada bir tane
kristalde bir akma var mı yok dostum o
toplu haldeki hareketten dolayı akmay
mış gibi zannediliyor ama o değil Bak
bir tane katı taneciğe Bak onda akma var
mı Yok sabit duruyor değil mi dostum
sıvıya Geldiğimizde tanecikler yine
temas halinde ama aralarındaki boşluk
nereden katıdan birazcık daha fazladır
bir bir tık daha böyle fazladır diyoruz
yoğunlukları katılara göre az gazlara
göre fazladır diyoruz ama bir iki tane
örnek var demiştik su ve bizmut özel
durum vardır Eee nedir katıya göre daha
düzensizdir gaza göre daha düzenlidir
ifadesini kullanıyoruz tanecikleri
titreşim ve öteleme hareketi yapar
öteleme hareketi varsa akışkanlık vardır
O yüzden sıvılar akışkandır suyu düşün
mesela başka belirli bir hacimleri var
ama belirli bir şekilleri yoktur Hangi
kabın içerisine koyarsan o şekli
almaktadır ki bunu hemen örneklendir
şöyle bakarsan Eğer Bak görüyor musun
şurada Benim sıvım var sıvı şu şekli
almakta Ben mesela bak ters çeviriyorum
Aha ters çevirdim gördün mü şuranın
şeklini aldı böyle farklı bir şekil aldı
Yani sıvılar ne yapıyor konulduğu kabın
doldurduğu kısmının şeklini alıyor
diyoruz devam ettiğimizde başka ne var
sıkıştırılamazlar tanecikler arası
boşluk Çünkü azdır hala çok azdır o
yüzden sıkıştırılamaz olarak kabul
ediyoruz gaza baktığımızda ise
tanecikleri birbirinden bağımsız hareket
eder ve aralarındaki boşluk çok fazladır
Çok serbest hareket ettikleri için de ne
diyoruz Maddenin en düzensiz halidir
diyoruz yoğunlukları katı ve sıvılara
göre oldukça azdır tanecikleri titreşim
öteleme ve dönme hareketi yapmaktadırlar
bunu Bilmemiz gerekiyor önemli bir
ifadedir dostum belirli bir hacimleri de
yoktur belirli bir şekilleri de yoktur
Hangi kabın içerisine koyarsan koy o
kabın tamamını doldurmaktadır o kabın
hacmi Neyse gazın hacmi de odur şekli de
odur mesela Yani gazlar konulduğu kabın
tamamını doldurmaktadır
sıkıştırılabilirler Çünkü tanecikler
arası boşluk çok fazla ve akışkandır L
Çünkü öteleme hareketi yapıyor plazmaya
geldiğimizde ise tanecikler arası boşluk
katı ve sıvılara göre nedir daha
fazladır gazlarla çok yorumlamam onu
yoğunlukları katı ve sıvılardan daha
azdır nötrdür L ama İçerisinde pozitif
ve negatif ne yükler taşımaktadırlar
Çünkü plazma dediğimiz şey nedir Aslında
içerisinde iyon Elektron ve bu bilimum
başka molekül atom hepsini bulundurur
Aynı maddenin böyle bir yapıya sahiptir
ona Mesela
iyonlaştırıcı bir haldir onu da
söyleyelim enerjisi diğer hallere göre
oldukça yüksektir belirli bir hacimleri
ve şekilleri yoktur elektriği iletirler
Çünkü içerisinde artı ve eksi yapılar
bulunmakta Ve akışkan özelliğe
sahiptirler diyoruz diyebilirsin hocam
akışkan özelliğe sahiptirler bana örnek
versene lavı örnek vereyim mesela nedir
akışkandır değil mi buna en iyi
örneklerden bir tanesidir Şimdi suyun
farklı hallerde olması katı sıvı gaz
halleri var Farklı hallerde olması acaba
bize nasıl fayda sağlıyor su döngüsünde
çok fayda sağlıyor bak Su döngüsü nasıl
gerçekleşen bir olaydır mesela Göller
denizler var burada havada sıcak Mesela
ben şu anda sıcak bir zamanda Bu dersi
sana anlatıyorum Ve burada su
buharlaşıyor su buharlaşıyor
buharlaşıyor buharlaşıyor nem diyoruz ya
havada nem olarak toplanıyor bir sürü
nem var bu daha sonra yükseliyor Bu
Dağlarda şurada burada yüksek yerlerde
bazen de normal şeyde herhangi bir bir
yerde de olabiliyor yükseliyor Soğuk
havayla karşılaşınca yoğuşma
gerçekleşiyor ve orada Su damlalarına
dönüşebiliyor çok soğuk havayla
karşılaştığında buz kristali halinde
yani daha doğrusu buz topları halinde ne
oluyor dolu olarak yağabilir veya işte
orada kırlaşma olayı gerçekleştirerek
kar halinde de yağabilir bak ne oldu
katı hale dönüşebilir sıvı hale
dönüşebilir zaten buradan gaz halinde
yukarıya çıkmıştı İşte bu farklı
hallerde olması su döngüsünü sağlamakta
Peki su döngüsü bize ne tür bir fayda
sağlamakta şöyle Ben şu an Mesela e
belki derse başlamadan önce veya İşte
dersten sonra bilmiyorum tuvalete
gideceksin örnek veriyorum tuvalette Ne
yapıyorsun işte işini gördün Neyse şimdi
o kısıma girmiyorum o detaya girmiyorum
Eee Sonrasında ne yapıyorsun sifona
bastın su gitti mi gitti güzel bayağı
bir su gönderdin o su nereye gidiyor
işte arıtma tesislerine şuraya Buraya
böyle açık havuzlara gidiyor Oradan da
arıtılıp bazen de ne oluyor denizlere
yollanıyor işte oradaki su ne oluyor
buharlaşıyor bak Sadece su buharlaşıyor
kirli suydu buharlaştı gökyüzünde tek
tekrar yoğuş hop tekrar bize ulaştı
temiz bir halde Yani su döngüsü Neyi
sağlıyormuş suyun temizlenmesini
sağlıyormuş değil mi Bunu da buradan
söylemiş olalım yani su döngüsünde
sürekli olan şeyleri de düşünürsek
buharlaşma var mı var yoğuşma var mı var
donma var mı var erime var mı var Mesela
bu hal değişimlerinin hepsi
görülebilmekte dostum Hatta Kırağılaşma
ve süblimleşme de gerçekleşmekte Demin
söylemiştim İşte bu suyun farklı
fiziksel hallerde olmasının ne tür
faydaları vardır İşte birisi kirlenen su
doğal yollardan temizlenmiş oluyor Başka
sıvı haldeki su içme su olarak
kullanmaktayız veya işte sulama suyu
olarak kullanmaktayız e haliyle
canlılığın devam etmesi için sıvı
haldeki suya ihtiyacımız var işte vücut
sıcaklığının dengelenmesi metabolik
faaliyetlerin devam etmesi için bu sıvı
suya ihtiyacımız var mesela buzun
yoğunluğu suyunkinden küçük olduğu için
ne oluyor su işte buz Daha doğrusu suyun
üzerinde yüzüyor bu işte şeyler buz
dağları falan filan ne oluyor suyun
üzerinde yüzebilmek bunun da ayrı bir
faydası var ki işte Soğuk havalarda ne
oluyor denizler yüz yüzeyden donmaya
başlıyor veya Göller yüzeyden donuyor
altta hala sıvı su var Balıklar orada
yaşamını devam ettirebiliyor izole bir
ortam sağlamış oluyor Eğer dipten
donmaya başlasaydı yani suyun buzun
yoğunluğu sudan büyük olsaydı dipten
donmaya başlayacaktı balıklar ne
olacaktı ölmüş olacaktı işte sıvının
Daha doğrusu suyun Eee yoğunluğunun
küçük olması buz halinin sıvıdan daha
düşük olmasının faydası denizler göller
yüzeyden donmakta ve altında canlılık
devam edebilmekte dostum Mesela bu
diyoruz ya ya hava çok nemli Tamam çok
nemli olunca kötü ama hiç nem olmayınca
da kötü Çünkü solunumu kolaylaştıran bir
şeydir nem belirli oranda olması gerekir
Ayrıca atmosferde belirli bir miktarda
nem olması gerekiyor ki Sera etkisi
gerçekleşsin hocam Sera etkisi kötü
değil miydi Sera gazları falan şöyle bir
şey var belirli bir oranda Sera etkisine
ihtiyacımız var Eğer olmasaydı -15 miydi
öyle bir sıcaklığa düşüyor mesela havada
su buharı falan olmasa ne oluyor -15
lira falan düşüyor Bu da bizim için pek
de iyi bir şey değil bundan dolayı
havada belirli bir miktarda su su buharı
yani nem olması gerekiyor Onu da
söyleyelim Peki bu hal değişim olayları
günlük hayatımızda endüstride falan
faydalı mıdır Evet faydalıdır ki Bunlara
örnek verelim mesela LPG LNG itici
gazlar soğutucu gazlar diye bir şey
vardır ki önce lpg'den bahsedelim bunu
mesela araçlarda kullanıyoruz evlerde
tüp olarak kullanıyoruz veya pikniklerde
piknik tüpü olarak kullanıyoruz işte
çoğunluğu bütan ve propan gazı olan ki
çoğunluk bütan Tabii ki bütan ve propan
gazlarından oluşan bir karışımdır hemen
örneklendir istersen şöyle göstereyim
sana dostum bak şunun içerisinde Mesela
ne varmış Bak görüyor musun bütan
şeklinde yazıyor he Şurada şöyle
yakından göstereyim sana Bak bütan
yazıyor Gördün mü çakmak gazı Mesela bu
bunun içerisine sıkıştırılmış halde
bırakıyor bu LPG Mesela şöyle de
tetiğine bak basayım şöyle de sen de gör
Öf koktu be Ulan şimdi patlatacağız
falan Neyse riske atmayayım kendimi yani
bunda ne var LPG var mesela başka bu e
nerelerde görebilirsin dediğim gibi İşte
bu şeylerde benzin istasyonlarında falan
bu şeyle tüple çalışan araçlar var ya
onlarda mesela LPG kullanılmakta devam
edelim diyor ki Ham petrolün rafinasyonu
ile ve doğalgazın çeşitli işlemlerden
geçirilmesiyle elde edilir Evet ham
petrol rafine edildiğinde oradaki Gaz
halindeki maddeler vardır hidrokarbonlar
bütan da propan da işte bunları ayırarak
ne yapıyoruz LPG elde ediyoruz yanıcıdır
patlayıcıdır çok tehlikeli bir maddedir
mutfakta sanayide taşıtlarda
kullanmaktayız Bak burada taşıttı
kullanımına dair bir örnek var Bu da
mutfak tüpleri mesela şu piknik tüpü ne
yapıyoruz bol miktarda kullanıyoruz
Bununla ilgili bilm bil gereken çok
önemli bir şey var dostum o da şudur
yaklaşık 250 litrelik bütan propan
karışımı Şöyle sıkıştırıldığında 1 lre
LPG'ye dönüşmektedir hocam LPG diyorsun
da LPG ne demekti sıvılaştırılmış Petrol
gazı likit petrogaz anlamında
kullanılmakta dostum bir de şu var tabii
ki bunlar benzine göre e atmosfere daha
az karbondioksit vermekte ama yine
zararlı canım Yani yine karbondioksit
veriyor sadece benzine göre % 120 daha
az karbondioksit vermekte onu da
bilmemiz lazım gelelim bir diğer neye
sıkıştırılmış gazımı O da ne LNG Bu da
endüstride bol miktarda kullanmakta
likit Natural gaz yani sıvılaştırılmış
doğal gaz diye ifade ediliyor Natural
doğal oradan geliyor şöyle bir şeydir
Bunun yaklaşık % 90'ı metan gazıdır geri
kalan kısmı etan propan bütan gibi
maddelerdir bunlardan oluşan bir
karışımdır ve şöyle bir şey vardır
yaklaşık bunun 600 litresini
sıkıştırdığında 1 lre LNG elde
edebilirsin LNG a o zaman güzel
sıkıştırılabilir Peki acaba nerelerde
kullanılıyor işte bunu daha çok evlerde
ne yapıyorduk işte eee yemek pişirmek
için kullanıyorduk değil mi ısınmak için
kullanıyorduk aynı şekilde ısınmak için
kullanılıyor doğru elektrik üretiminde
Türkiye'deki mesela termik santrallerin
bir kısmı doğalgaz yakarak elektrik
üretmekte sıcak hava eldesi işte kızgın
yağ eldesi buhar eldesi pişirme kurutma
fırınları seramik cam sanayi falan gibi
Birçok yerde kullanılmakta yani doğal
gazı tercih ettiğinde hem atmosfere Bir
tık daha az zarar vermiş olursun yine
veriyorsun ama daha az zarar veriyorsun
Kime göre kömüre göre mesela o yüzden
tercih ediliyor depolanması işte
taşınması kolaydır ki bak bu 600 litreyi
1 lre şeklinde gösteriyoruz ya Şurayı
Görüyor musun bak Şunların her birisi
apartman boyutunda şeyler eee tanklar bu
tankların Mesela bir tanesinin
sallıyorum şu anda 100 ton olduğunu
düşünsek tamam mı Ya da işte diğer bir
ifadeyle 100.000 lre olduğunu düşünsek
bir tanesini e 4 tane var Ne oldu
400.000 L oldu LNG olarak bak LNG taşı
400.000 lre LNG taşıdığını düşün Ee 600
kat sıkıştırıldığında elde ediliyordu
değil mi yani bunu bir de 600 ile
çarparsan o kadar litre ne elde etmiş
oluyorsun doğal gaz elde etmiş oluyorsun
O yüzden bu şekilde gemilerle
taşınmasında da sakınca yoktur gayet
iyidir Sadece yanında e çakmakla veya
işte sigarayla yaklaşmamak lazım
Mümkünse yoksa Alen musk'ın roketinde
daha hızlı bir şekilde Mars'a
ulaşabilirsin burada bak Ayrıca neyle
işte boru hatlarıyla da
taşınabilmektedir o da ayrı bir şekilde
gösterilmiş Türkiye'de de var
biliyorsunuz gelelim iti i gazlara itici
gazlar sıkışma ve genleşme özelliğiyle
işte maddeleri ne yapıyor beraberinde
dışarıya çıkartmış oluyor mesela bak
şöyle bir örnek göstereyim sana şu
Mesela benim saç spreyim işte alıyorsun
mesela içerisinde saçı sabit tutacak
şeyler var değil mi Ne yapıyorum Ben
bunu İşte getiriyorum şöyle tetiğine
bastığımda ne yapıyor işte içindeki
madde çıkıyor saçı sabitliyor değil mi
İşte He yani itici gaz var Bunun
içerisinde etken madde ki saçı
sabitlemek için kullandığım madde
bununla beraber dışarıya çıkmış oluyor
sadece bu bu değil tabii ki mesela neyde
vardı bu eee deodorantlarda da aynı şey
söz konusu başka Bazı ilaçlar var Ben
mesela işte şeyden omurgam daki kırıktan
dolayı ağrılarım oruyor bazı spreyler
var işte sırtıma sıktığım Akşamları
falan o da mesela aynı tetiğine
basıyorum O ilaç beraberinde çıkıyor
sırtıma işte sürüyorum falan iyi geliyor
mesela işte bunun gibi yani e itici
gazlar beraberindeki maddeyi dışarıya
çıkartmak için kapalı kapta dışarıya
çıkartmak için basınçlı bir şekilde
sıkıştırılmış gazlardır diyoruz işte
burada da gösteriyor oda parfümleri
böcek ilaçları neyler işte eee
deodorantlar gibi örnekler verebiliriz
mesela boya tabancalarının çalışma
prensibi de budur O şey yapar havayı
sıkıştırır beraberinde püskürtün ce
boyayla beraber çıkıp ne yapıyor
yüzeyleri boyayabilir Burada tabii ki
şöyle bir şey vardır Eee özellikle hatta
bak şuna da bakmak istiyorum Eee şöyle
Heh ekranı getirdim kendime zaten
birazdan Şeyi göstereceğim diğerinde
şurada bir şeye bakacağım bakıyorum
bakıyorum görebilecek miyim bakalım
Türkiye diyor He uygulama şekli uyarılar
geç la uygulama şeklini Hah aşağıya
bakıyorduk alkol var mış işte bütan
varmış izobütan varmış propan varmış
güzel bunda mesela zararlı itici gazlar
yok bunda mesela eskiden daha çok şu
kullanılıyordu diyorlardı ki işte ne
kullanalım Biz bunda şey
kloroflorokarbon gazı kullanalım
diyorlardı kloroflorokarbon gazı itici
bir gazdır çok ciddi soğutan bir gazdır
Ayrıca Eee bu gaz mesela atmosfere zarar
veriyor yani daha doğrusu atmosferden
çok Ozon tabakasına zarar veriyor O
yüzden kullanımı şu anda yasaklandı ne
yapıyorlar işte bütan propan gibi
maddeler koyuyorlar itici gaz olarak
Burada da onu söylüyor işte kimler
kullanılmakta karbondioksit
kullanılmakta İşte diazot monoksit
kullanılmakta bu itici gaz olarak ki
diazot monoksit kullanılanı çok da
tavsiye etmeyeceğim çünkü Eee diazot
monoksit gülme gazıdır yani bayıltıcı
dır fazla çekersen bayılırsın az
miktarda da gülmekten bayıltır adamı
bayağı bir şeydir onun kullanıldığını da
ben pek görmedim açıkçası öyle bir itici
gaz bulsam Ben denerim de daha henüz
denk gelmedim açık söyleyeyim hı başka
Ayrıca mesela LPG Demin de göstermiştim
ya şunda mesela tetiğe basmıştım tetiğe
bastım ne oluyordu işte gaz dışarı
çıkıyordu Yani aslında LPG de bir çeşit
itici gaz olarak kullanılabilir mi Evet
kullanılabilir geldik Bir diğer kısmımı
o da soğutucu gazlar soğutucu gazların
özelliği şudur sıkıştığında sıkıştırıyor
işte böyle şey yapıyor tetiğe basıp gaz
haline dönüşürken çevresinden ısı alıp
çevrenin soğumasına sebep oluyor bu
mesela demin bu saç spreyini sıktığımda
da aynısını hissettim onda da var çünkü
gazlar sıkıştı ya sıv hale geldi bir
tetikle bastın gaz haline dönüşürken
etrafından ısı alır etrafından ısı
aldığında da ne olur soğutur şöyle
göstereyim bak bunu birkaç kere
yapmıştım Daha önceden de mesela avucunu
şöyle bak yap Koklama yani şu an ağzın
kokuyorsa İdare et onu Bak yaptığında
sıcak hava gelir ama yaptığında soğuk
hava gelir E aynı ciğerden gelmiyor mu
bu gaz e geliyor karbondioksit ve su
ağız açık bir şekilde üflediğinde
ciğerindeki sıcaklığı doğrudan buraya
veriyor ama Ağzını büzdü ya büzdü de gaz
sıkıştı dışarı çıkarken de genleşiyor
etrafından ısı almış oluyor o yüzden
yaptığında soğumuş oluyor tamam mı
dostum İşte soğutucu Ak Akışkanların
çalışma prensip prensibi tam olarak
böyledir sıkıştırırsa sıvı hale
getirirsin sonra küçücük bir delikten
böyle toplu iğne gibi ucu gibi bir
delikten bir gönderirsin o gazı
genleşirken etrafından ısıyı bir alır
Hatta neye dönüşür buza dönüşür ki
buzdolaplarında klimalarda bu şekilde
çalışmakta sistem ne yazık ki onlarda
işte freon gazı dediğimiz
kloroflorokarbon gazı kullanılmaktaydı
şimdi yavaş yavaş o da değişiyor klima
gazları mesela atmosfere ciddi zarar
verebilmektedir burada Eee işte
buharlaşırken ortamdan Isı alan ve
ortamın sıcaklığının düşmesine sebep
olan gazlara soğutucu gaz diyoruz işte
bunların soğutucu Akışkanların ne olması
gerekiyor uygun basınçta kolaylıkla
sıvılaşabilir ve bıraktığında kolaylıkla
genleşebilir Yani tekrar gaz haline
dönüşmesi gerekiyor Mesela çok zor sıvı
hale geliyorsa o bir Soğutucu akışkan
olarak kullanmanın bir anlamı yok oda
sıcaklığında buhar fazında olması
gerekiyor ki onları zaten nerede AYT
kısmında detaylı bir şekilde gazlar
konusunda anlatacağız İşte bu gazların
hal değişiminden Daha doğrusu maddelerin
hal değişiminden bu gazların
sıkıştırılması falan filan nerede
faydalanıyoruz işte ilaçlama
sistemlerinde otob boyama sistemlerinde
Mesela bu işte sıvı haldeki de başka
fren sistemlerinde kullanıyoruz sıvı
halde kullanılır hidrolik diyoruz ya
hidro sıvı işte oksijen tüplerinde sıcak
hava balonlarında sıcak ısınan hava
yükselir bak hepsinde Ne yapıyorsun
Maddenin hal değişimini bariz bir
şekilde kullanıyorsun Şimdi şöyle bir
şey var dostum havadan azot ve oksijen
gazı da elde edebiliyorsun ya Nasıl
yapacağız bunu şimdi havanın % 78'i
neydi azotu % 21'i neydi yaklaşık olarak
oksijendir işte hava havayı alıyorlar
sıkıştırıp soğutuyorlar sıkıştırıp
soğuttuğunuz
gaz halinde o sırada oksijen hala sıvı
halde sıvı oksijeni de bu taraftan
ayırıyor havadan oksijen ve azot
gazlarını bu şekilde elde edebiliyorlar
mesela burada da onu gösteriyor işte 40
atmosfer basınçta sıkıştırılarak sıvı
hale getiriliyor hava önce e ne
yapıyormuş işte yavaş yavaş işte
geçiriliyor muu Ne yapıyormuş içindeki
suyu karbondioksiti şunu bunu katılaşan
maddeleri uzaklaştırıyor Ondan sonra
kalan saf karışımı da yavaş yavaş
ısıtarak azot ve oksijen elde ediyor
burada işte azot gazının -16 s derecede
oksijenin -13 sant derecede sıvı olarak
elde edildiğinden bahsediyor Dostum
şimdi gelelim katılara katılar önemli
bir kısımdır buradan soru gelebilir mi
Evet gelebilir dostum sıvıları Evet bir
süredir soruyor Ama bu sene katılardan
sormayacak diye bir anlam yok hemen
bakalım neler var katılarla ilgili bir
önce katı türlerini bilmen lazım iki
çeşit katı türümüz vardır Birisi Amorf
katılar diğeri de kristal katılar ama
kristal katılar kendi içerisinde dört
başlıkta toplanıyor metalik kristal
iyonik kristal kovalent kristal ve
moleküler kristal olarak dört başlıkta
toplanıyor Ya da işte iyonik katı
moleküler katı kovalent katı ve metalik
katı olarak söylüyoruz ş Amorf
katılardan bahsedelim adı üstüne bak
Amorf şekilsiz demektir yani belirli bir
kristal yapısı yoktur tane C ikleri
düzensiz istiflenmiş burada onu söylüyor
işte belirli bir düzenli şekli yoktur
geometrik şekli yoktur bunlara Amorf
katı demekte yiz Amorf katılar
tanecikleri Gelişi güzel
istiflenmis bunlar da serttir Sonuçta
katı mı katı katıdır serttir
sıkıştırılamazlar bunda herhangi bir
şeyimiz yok mesela mesela mesela mesela
Aha ya bu cam Bak şurada göstereyim şu
camı mesela nedir Amorf katıdır başka
günlük hayattan bir örnek daha
göstereyim hemen gösteriyorum bir saniye
bekle bir dakika bir dakika Aha mesela
şu plastik şöyle plastiği de örnek
gösterelim görüyor musun bu da aynı
şekilde Amorf katıdır ısıtıldığında
Amorf katıların en önemli özelliğini
söyleyeyim ısıtıldığında önce yumuşar
işte ona Biz camsı geçiş sıcaklığı
diyoruz burada da onu söylüyor işte
ısıtıldıklarında yumuşayarak akıcı hale
gelen maddelere Yani önce yumuşayan
Erimeden önce önce yumuşayan maddelere
ne diyoruz biz Amorf katı diyoruz Bu şey
işte o yumuşama olayına ise camsı geçiş
sıcaklığı Diyoruz ki camsı geçiş
sıcaklığı dediğime göre Amorf katıların
ilk örneği camdır sonra lastik plastik
var kauçuk var Tereyağı var Bunlar en
önemli neyler dostum Amorf katıya
örnekler ha abart abilir im işte kaşar
peyniri Şudur budur onları da örnek
verebilirim de gerek Bunlar bizim için
yeterli şöyle bir şey söyleyeyim Amorf
katıların sert olmak dışında birçok
özelliği Aslında sıvıya benzemekte ki
şöyle bir şey cam için mesela yıllarca
sıvı dediler sebebi de şu işte böyle E
çok uzun vadede o yumuşama özelliğinden
dolayı mesela camların alt kısmında
kalın laşma olduğunu ama bu söylediğim
çok çok uzun yıllardan bahsediyoruz
böyle bir özelliği Demek ki A cam
akışkan mış gibi bir sıvıyı gibi bir
algı ortaya çıkıyor Hayır Amorf katıdır
sadece işte belirli özellikleri sıvıya
benzemektedir ama sonuçta serttir
sıkıştırılamazlar onlar değişmiyor
kristal katı dediğimizde ise bunların
belirli bir geometrik şekli vardır Heh
burada da onu söylüyor belirli bir
geometrik düzene göre istiflenmiş
katılara biz kristal katı diyoruz
serttir sıkıştırılamazlar bakalım günlük
hayatta gördüğümüz birçok madde katı
haldeki maddenin kristal katı olduğunu
söylemiş olalım hemen örneklendir önce
iyonik katıdan bahsedelim mesela iyonik
katı nedir Adı üstünde tanecikler
arasında iyonik bağlar olacak yani
içerisindeki tanecikler anyon ve
katyonda oluşan elektrostatik çekimlerle
bir arada bulunan iyonik katılar olması
yani iyonik maddeler olması gerekiyor
belirli bir geometrik düzeni var mı
Bunların Evet neydi şeylerin iyonik
bağlı bileşikler birim hücre yapılıy dı
değil mi Hepsinin kendine özgü böyle
birim hücre yapıları mevcuttur Kimisi
kübik Kimisi işte tetragonal falan böyle
çeşit çeşit şekilleri var mesela mesela
günlük hayattan bir tane örnek vereyim
şurada Mesela benim daha önceden değerli
taşlar diye bir şeyim vardı koleksiyonum
vardı şöyle bakayım yakından
gösterebilecek göstereyim dostum Bak
şimdi şöyle bak şöyle görülüyor mu
bakayım Heh işte bu şunun Mesela yani
şeyden o değerli taş koleksiyonunda Bunu
bana şey diye Yakut diye Verdiler de
öyle şey değil tabii o değerli çok
değerli yakuttan bahsetmiyoruz bu Tabii
ki kalitesiz olanından bahsediyoruz bu
Mesela işte içerisinde iyonik katılar
yok mu var Eee böyle bir yapıdan
bahsediyoruz daha birçok şey var sofra
tuzu o şeyler var ya Çankırı tuzu falan
var Kemah tuzu var böyle Kaya halinde
onlar mesela nedir işte iyonik katıya
örnektir başka başka Hemen şöyle
gösterelim bir daha Eee neydi
tanecikleri birim hücre yapılıy diı
demiştik sodyum klorür örnek verebiliriz
kalsiyum sülfürü örnek verebiliriz
magnezyum nitrat ya iyonik bağlı
bileşikleri örnek ver bu kadar basit
Hatta tebeşir bile budur Kalsiyum
karbonat iyonik bağlıdır mesela iyonik
katı di örnek verebilirsin mermeri örnek
verebilirsin mesela He iyonik katılarda
neydi tanecikler genellikle anyon ve
katyonların işte Eee ne olmasıyla bir
arada bulunmasıyla meydana geliyordu
iyonik katılarda bilmen gereken şey
anyonlar katyonda daha büyük oluyor
çünkü anyon ne yapıyordu elektron
alıyordu elektron aldığı için çapı
artıyordu katyon ne yapıyordu elektron
verdiği için çapı küçülüyordu ya bu
bilgi Gerekli mi Aslında bu neydi şey de
periyodik sistemle ilgili bağlantılı bir
kısımı o yüzden söylüyorum başka İşte bu
nedenle iyonik katılarda anyonların
oluşturduğu boşluklara katyonlar yerleşe
bilmekte ne oluyor Böylelikle İşte o
kristal yapı meydana geliyor dostum e
iyonik bağlı bileşikler neydi sertti
işlenemez yani vurduğunda dağılıyordu
kırılgan bir yapıya sahip tel ve levhe
haline getirilemiyor iyonik bağlı
bileşikler katı halde kırılgandır L bunu
da unutma katı halde Elektrik akımını il
etmiyorlardı suda çözündüğünde ya da
sıvı halde elektriği iletiyor lardı Bu
da iyonik bağlı bileşikler konusuna bak
bir dönüş yapıp geri dönmüş olduk
kovalent katı dediğimizde ise kovalent
katılar çok sayıda ametal atomunun güçlü
kovalent bağlarla bir arada bulunmasıyla
oluşur kovalent ağ örgüsü bulunmaktadır
ki buna en iyi örneklerden bir tanesi
elmastır bir tanesi de nedir grafitti
Dostum yani Karbonun Neyi
allotroplarından bahsediyoruz işte
burada Eee ne oluyor işte moleküller
arasında her yöne uzanan bir kovalent ağ
örgüsü meydana geliyor elmastaki gibi
mesela bak burada gösteriyor şu
elmastaki görünüm Bu da grafitteki
görünüm Bunlar kovalent katılardır hocam
kovalent katılara örnek ver dediğinde
aklına gelecek şeyler birisi Elmas
birisi grafit bitti mi Hayır bir de
silisyumlu bileşikler var ki onu da sana
hemen şöyle göstereyim dostum Bak şöyle
yakından göstereyim dur He burada lan
beni odaklama bunu odakla Heh Gördün mü
bak şu işte Bu ne biliyor musun kuvars
yani silisyum oksit kristali silisyumlu
bileşikler nedir biliyor musun dostum
kovalent katıdır onu da şöyle yine
yerine yerleştirelim böyle kutularına
koyuyorum ki zarar görmesinler Heh O
zaman ne diyoruz karbon yani Karbonun
allotropları Elmas grafit Bir de
silisyumlu bileşikler bak silisyum
Karbür silisyum oksit silisyum nitrür
gibi örnekler Bunlar kovalent katılara
örnek olarak verilebilmektedir kovalent
katılardan özellikle elmastan şunu
bahsedebiliriz ki erime noktası çok
yüksektir çok serttir yani ne yapar camı
şunu bunu her şeyi kesebilir kolay kolay
dağıtamaz sın değil mi İşte burada da
söylüyor işte eee diğer kovalent
katıların erime ve kaynama noktaları
elmas ve Karsa göre ne olacaktır düşük
olacaktır Ama elmas ve kuvarsın çok
yüksektir onu söylememiz lazım moleküler
katılar dediğimizde ise tanecikler
arasında moleküller arası etkileşimler
bulunur Nasıl yani şu dipol dipol başka
eee şey London kuvvetleri başka hidrojen
Bağları yani tanecikleri arasında
moleküller arasında dipol dipol London
ve Hidrojen bağı zayıf etkileşimleri
bulunan katılara Biz moleküler katı
diyoruz mesela moleküler katılara en iyi
örnek kuru buzdur karbondioksitin katı
hali mesela iyot katısı Naftalin başka
başka başka başka örnek verebilir miyiz
katı halde Neyi örnek verebiliriz başka
buz mesela Ama şöyle bir şey bu
yazdıklarım nedir apolar moleküllerde
yani London kuvveti içerenleri glikoz
yani şeker başka E su yani buz başka
amonyak bunların katı halleri ise ne
olacaktır tanecikler arasında hidrojen
bağlarının Etkin olduğu kovalent katılar
şey moleküler katılar olacaktır kovalent
değil mesela burada da polar bir
molekülden bahsetmiş bunda da dipol
dipol etkilidir diyor CO2 katısı çok
kullanılmaz Burada en çok kullanılan ya
moleküler katılara örnek var dediğinde
kuru buz normal buz iyot şeker başka ya
En çok bunları bir de Naftalin bunları
çok görürsün tamam mı dostum şu vardır
moleküler katıların tane L arasındaki
etkileşim iyonik katılar ve kovalent
katılardan daha düşüktür Çünkü iyonik
katılarda İyonik bağ var şeyde kovalent
katılarda kovalent bağı var E moleküler
katılarda zayıf etkileşimler var E
haliyle ne olacaktır bunların erime ve
kaynama noktaları diğerlerine göre
genellikle düşük olacaktır diyoruz
burada da onu söylüyor işte Mesela
Parafin dediğimiz mumdur bu mesela
Naftalin Bunlar da yumuşaktır Bir tık
böyle daha yumuşak bir özelliğe
sahiptirler e haliyle elektriği ve ısıyı
da iletmeye ya da çok az iletecek erdir
diyebiliriz ısı için metalik katılar
dediğimizde haliyle tanecikler arasında
hangi bağ olması lazım metalik bağ
olması lazım Bu kadar basit pozitif
yüklü metal iyonlarının neydi elektron
Denizi içerisinde bulunması yani metalik
neyden bahsediyorum bağdan bahsediyorum
işte tanecikler arasında metalik bağ
bulunan metalik katılara Biz metalik
katı diyoruz ya da işte metalik kristal
diyoruz ya tüm metalleri düşün işte
bakırı düşün alüminyumu düşün altını
düşün y bir sürü örnek verebiliriz
burada Eee İşte bunlar tel ve Lev haline
getirilebilir şekillendirilebilir Isı ve
elektriği iyi iletirler erime ve kaynama
noktaları yüksektir Burada da söylüyoruz
sadece düşük olan bir şey var galyum var
mesela galyum 30 sant derecede
eriyebilir Keşke olsa da gösterseydin
Mesela galyum şöyle avucuna al erime
noktasına bakar mısın
29.88 nasıl eritecek olabilir mi olamaz
değil mi erime noktası oldukça yüksektir
işte burada da örnek vermiş altın çinko
bakır gümüş potasyum sodyum Neyse bunlar
katı haldeki metaller metalik katı Bu
kadar basit Hadi şimdi bunlarla ilgili
sorulara bakalım nasıl sorularımız
varmış İlk soruda bakalım ne diyor
maddenin katı sıvı gaz hallerinin
özellikleri ile ilgili olarak yukarıda
doğru ve yanlış tablosu verilmiştir
hatalı işaretleme sayısını soruyor bize
diyor ki belirli bir şekli yoktur
katıların vardı E bu O zaman yanlış
işaretlenmiş yanlışları yuvarlak içine
alıyorum Sıvıların belirli bir şekli
yoktur Hım burada vardır gibi
anlaşılıyor yoktur a çarpı koyduğuna
göre bu da yanlış işaretlenmiş Gazların
belirli bir şekli yoktur Evet bu doğru
işaretlenmiş sıkıştırılabilir katılar
sıkıştırılamaz çarpı koyması gerekirken
tik koymuş gitti E sıvılar da
sıkıştırılamazlar sıkıştırılabilir çarpı
koymuş Hayır tik olması gerekiyordu
diyor ki tanecikleri sadece titreşim
hareketi yapar Evet katılar için
doğruydu bu sıvılar için yanlıştı Bu da
doğru gazlar için de yanlıştı Çünkü
gazların tanecikleri titreşim öteleme
dönme hareketi yapar bu gitti 5 tane
yanlış gördüm cevap da B seçeneğidir
ikinci sorumuz dah bana bir şeyler
vermiş diyor ki x y z hallerini soruyor
bakalım gerçekleşen hal değişimi
sonucunda yani x maddesi hal değişimi
gerçekleştiriyor muu daha düzensiz hale
geliyormuş o zaman katı ya da sıvı
olabilir gaz değil daha düzensiz hale
gelebildiği göre daha öncekilerden bir
tanesi bu dursun bakalım o y diyor ki
maddenin süblimleşmesi sonucunda oluşan
fiziksel haldir süblimleşme katıdan gaza
dönüştü O zaman y süblimleşme sonucu
oluşuyorsa y gazmı çok güzel bunu işaret
dedik diyor ki tanecikleri birbirine
temas halinde olan ve yer değiştiremeyiz
iksel haldir tanecik yer
değiştiremiyorsan öteleme hareketi
yapmıyor ve tanecikleri temas halinde
öteleme hareketi yapmıyorsa tanecikler
temas halinde ise Z katıymış Z'nin katı
olduğunu bulduk x de neydi gazdan önceki
hallerden biriydi E buna ne kaldı bir
tane sıvı kaldı zaten cevap da C
seçeneği oldu 3te diyor ki aşağıdaki
kavramlardan hangisinin tanımı yukarıda
verilmemiştir Gaz halindeki bir maddenin
plazma haline geçişi plazma hale geçiş
iyonizasyonu var mı var Kırağılaşma
sonucunda oluşan fiziksel hal
Kırağılaşma gazın katı katıya
dönüşmesiyle yapabildiği hareket türü
katılar titreşim sıvılar titreşim
öteleme gazlar titreşim öteleme dönme
hepsinde titreşim var Aha bu da tamam
maddenin hem sıvı hem de gaz halinde
bulunan ortak özelliktir akışkan olması
var başka öteleme hareketi yapması var
akıcılık yazmış burada cevap ne çıktı C
seçeneği süblimleşme 4'e geldik diyor ki
maddenin fiziksel halleri ile ilgili
ifadelerden hangisi yanlıştır bakalım su
ve bizmut gibi birkaç örnek dışında
Maddenin en yoğun hali katı haldir Evet
doğrudur özellikle söylemiştik sıvı ve
gaz haldeki taneciklerin ortak özelliği
Her ikisinin de sıkıştırılabilir sıvılar
sıkıştırılamaz O yüzden şuna yanlış diye
koyduk ama devam edelim plazma halinde
pozitif ve negatif yüklü tanecikler
serbestçe hareket eder evet toplamda
nötrdür ama İçerisinde pozitif ve
negatif tanecikler bulunmaktaydı
plazmada Doğrudur belirli bir şeklin ve
hacmin olmaması gaz ve plazmanın ortak
özelliğidir Evet doğru bir ifadedir
maddeler sadece katı de akışkan değildir
Evet sıvı ve gaz halinde akışkandır
doğru bir ifade Biz cevabı bulduk cevap
B seçeneği 5te bakalım ne diyor Doğalgaz
ile ilgili olarak yukarıda verilen
bilgilerden hangileri doğrudur atmosfer
basınc basıncındaki doğalgaz -12 sant
dereceye soğutulduğunda yoğunlaşarak
sıvılaşır LNG dönüşür doğru LNG nin
hacmi doğal gazın hacmine göre yaklaşık
600 kat daha küçüktür Evet 600 litreyi
sıkıştırdığım da 1 litreye dönüşüyordu
doğru doğalgaz sadece boru hatlarıyla
taşınabilir Hayır o büyük tanker erle de
taşınab diğinde bahsetmiştim gitti cevap
ne olacaktır B seçeneği olacaktır 6da
diyor ki hava ve havanın damıtılması ile
ilgili olarak yukarıda verilen
bilgilerden hangileri yanlıştır havada
en fazla bulunan gaz oksijendir Hayır
azot gazıdır yanlış havanın damıtılması
sırasında öncelikli olarak azot ve
oksijen elde edilmeye çalışılır e
amacımız budur tabii ki o yüzden bu
doğrudur diyor ki Havanın damıtılmasıyla
elde edilen sıvı azot çok soğuktur ve
tıpta organların dondurulması için
kullanılır Evet sıvı azot -1 96 falandı
Evet organların dondurulması için
kullanılmaktadır Hatta ve hatta şöyle
söyleyeyim sana dostum Bununla ilgili
şey vardır tüp bebek servislerinde bu
embriyoları elde ederler işte sperm
yumurtayı alırlar dışarıda yapay
döllenme sonucunda embriyo elde
edilirler embriyo elde edildikten sonra
yaşayan embriyolar böyle tüplere
yerleştirilir İşte o tüp bebek ifadesi
de oradan gelmektedir Yoksa gidip de
piknik tüpünün içine koymuyorlar yani o
cam tüpe koydukları için böyle oraya
yerleştiriyorlar embriyoyu Ondan sonra
bunu sıvı azotun içerisine koyuyorlar
sıvı azot ta ne oluyor donuyor O hücre
bölünmeleri duruyor Ne zaman ki işte eee
anne doğum için hazırlanıyor Ondan sonra
ne yapıyorlar onu alıyorlar Anne rahmine
transfer ediyorlar sonra orada çözülüp
işte Daha doğrusu çözülüp çoğalmaya
büyümeye başlayınca hemen Anne rahmine
aktarıyorlar Ondan sonra işte tutunuyor
falan filan çocuk oluyor tüp bebek
Mesela bu şekilde yapılmakta orada sıvı
azot çok önemli bir rol oynamakta Evet o
zaman bu doğruydu demiştik yanlışı
sorduğu için cevabımız yalnız bir a
seçeneği 7 sorumuza bakalım Diyor ki
Amorf ve kristal katılar ile ilgili
olarak yukarı da verilen bilgilerden
hangileri yanlıştır hem Amorf katılar
hem de kristal katılar ne sert ve
sıkıştırılamaz yapıdadır Evet doğru
Bunların ortak özelliğidir katılar
sıkıştırılamaz serttir bitti Amorf
katıların belirli bir geometrik yapıları
yoktur Evet doğru Bir ifadedir kristal
katıların tümünde kristali oluşturan
tanecikler arasında güçlü etkileşimler
vardır Hayır moleküler kristallerde ne
vardı Zayıf etkileşimler vardı Hidrojen
bağı dipol dipol başka London demiştik
şekerde kuru buzda normal buzda değil mi
o yüzden bu yanlıştır cevap yalnız 3 B
seçeneği olacaktır 8de bana iyot katısın
vermiş diyor ki iyot katısı süblimleşme
özelliğine sahip bir katıdır oda
koşullarında ısıtıldığında katı halden
doğrudan gaz haline geçmektedir bakalım
şimdi moleküler kristal yapıdadır ı2 ı2
Bir molekül Müdür evet molekül olduğu
için moleküler kristaldir doğru ı2
apolar mıdır aynı ametal atomlarından
oluşan bir madde e apolar olduğu için
tanecikler arasında yani moleküller
arasında London etkileşimi olacaktır Bu
da doğrudur zayıf London kuvvetleri
vardır uygun koşullarda sıvı hali elde
edilebilir ya basıncı ve sıcaklığı
ayarlarsan bunun sıvı halini de elde
edebilirsin doğru söylüyor O yüzden
cevap 1 2 3 e seçeneği olacaktır 9da ne
vermiş diyor ki yukarıda verilen mutfak
malzemelerinde malzemelerinin Amorf ya
da kristal katı olma durumları
hangilerinde doğru verilmiştir plastik
kaşık bak plastik Amorf dur doğru çelik
tencere metal Bu neydi metalik kristal
doğru cam tabak cam neydi Amorf doğru
cevap ne olacak o zaman hepsi e seçeneği
10 soruda diyor ki metalik katılarla
ilgili olarak aşağıda verilen bilgilerin
doğru ve yanlış sınıflandırması
hangisinde hata yapılmıştır Yani doğru
yanlış olarak tik koyulmuş hata yapılanı
soruyor diyor ki metal atomları arasında
oluşan güçlü etkileşimler içerir Evet
metalik bağ metal atomları arasındaki
güçlü etkileşimdir doğru işaretlenmiş
diyor ki serbest değerlik
elektronlarının metal atomları
arasındaki alışverişi ile oluşurlar
elektron alışverişi değil ne oluyor
elektronlar hareket ediyor doğru ama
burada bir alışverişten bahsetmiyoruz o
yüzden yanlış olması gerekiyor yanlış
dediği için doğru yüzeyleri parlaktır ve
Elektrik akımını iletirler metaller Evet
böyledir böyle olması gerekirken çarpı
koymuş bu yanlış Gördüğün gibi
işlenebilir tel ve levha haline
getirebilir metalik kristaller için
doğru bir ifadedir ki doğru denmiş Amorf
katı sınıfındadır Hayır canım metalik
katılar kristal katı sınıfındadır çarpı
demiş o yüzden doğru oluyor bu da yani
ne olacaktır Biz yanlışı bulduk C
seçeneğimiz yanlıştır 11 sorumuz da
yukarıda tanımlanan katı türleri
Aşağıdakilerden hangisinde doğru
verilmiştir diyor Diyor ki katyon ve
anyon arasında elektrostatik çekim
Kuvvetleri ile oluşan bir katıdır katyon
anyon elektrostatik iyonik bağdan
bahsediyor iyonik katı onu
işaretledikten göre yerleşmeye
tanecikler arasında düzen yok belirli
geometrik Yapı oluşturmayan katılar
Amorf katılardır cevap da ne olacaktır e
seçeneği olacaktır Evet dostum yorulduk
mu Bence güzelce yorulduk ne yapmış
olduk seninle maddenin fiziksel
hallerini ve bu fiziksel hallerin
endüstride hayatta nerelerde
kullanıldığını anlatmış olduk Sonra
katılardan bahsettik Dikkat ettiysen
katıları anlatırken nereyi daha çok
böyle kullanmış olduk kimyasal türler
arası etkileşimlerin o zayıf
etkileşimler kısmını kullanmış olduk
Yani orayı da bilmen gerekiyor unuttuğun
kısımlar varsa dön bir tekrar et
tavsiyemdir sonra ne yapıyorsun
ödevlendirme sayfasındaki testleri
çözüyorsun sonraki dersimizde de
kaldığımız yerden devam ediyoruz iki
fosfor bir asit kimya Bu kadar basit Bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere hoşça kal